or letting you know right after gate
this video is brought to you by raycon
going to talk about that a little later
but first there's a new Hellraiser movie
and I feel like I'm getting this video
to you a little late but here here's why
hear me out on this well I was sick this
week feeling much better now thank you
but that's not why I actually got the
opportunity to get the screener for this
movie about a week ago or so but when
you get the screener to screen a movie
at home that's not out yet for the
entire movie when you're watching it
there's this Watermark across the screen
Watermark like that just there the
entire time and I spend the entire movie
trying not to look at the watermark
watch the movie but I'm looking at the
watermark but I'm trying not to but I am
so as much as I wanted to do the smart
business decision thing of watching the
movie early so I can get the review up
when the Embargo lifted I wanted to
enjoy the movie Sans Watermark figure
I'll just watch the movie when it comes
out on Hulu so now I have enough talking
about that let's talk about it
foreign
[Music]
ERS directed by David Bruckner and it's
a 2022 reimagining of Clive Barker's
Hellraiser which is not to say it's a
remake of Hellraiser it's not like
Disney Live Action where you're like oh
it's the same plot same movie only worse
no it's not the same plot as the
original Hellraiser it's a new movie new
Hellraiser and in this movie this girl
and her boyfriend steal this box we all
know what the box is they don't but it's
obviously a puzzle and as every puzzle
begs to be solved the tinkering and the
clicking starts and then her friends
start disappearing because cenobites are
getting them I feel like I want to just
jump right into talking about the
cenobites because they were absolutely
the coolest part of the movie I mean
they're gonna be we you know they're
going to be I mean they should be anyway
which I guess is a positive for review
sake they are um new Pinhead female
Pinhead this time around that's right
it's very new for people who don't have
the internet Progressive maybe sorry to
tell you Hollywood rule 34 had you beat
on that one years ago I mean so I've
heard anyway for the sake of research
for this movie what are you doing don't
open that folder but the movie is very
subtle in rolling out the reveal of the
Seno bites I did like the slow trickle
of seeing more and more as the cenobites
kill more and more I'm sorry bring
pleasure to it was just great horror
great sound design great visuals ominous
music creepy sounds that the cenobites
are making the chatter you know the
teeth chattering ones there the lighting
is just dreary and you know someone's
gonna die the cenobites in the original
Hellraiser very black and white the
Santa bites this time around a fleshy
white and red color scheme they actually
look like some creatures from new
forexia in Magic the Gathering modern
yes but still horrific I appreciated the
fact that they modernized the look of
the cenobites but does not make it any
less horrific
their character models are still skin
that's been cut and peeled up over and
stapled to their shoulders or whatever
the [ __ ] and that's always been a big
thing in Hellraiser it's a thing that
they had to nail in this new Hellraiser
the body horror has to be horrific but
you just can't look away I will say for
a time in this movie I felt like this
movie was just one of those supernatural
movies my friends and I are getting
terrorized we have to investigate to
find out why this is happening you kind
of gotta bite a stick and get through
that to get to the good stuff which is
essentially the cenobites but at a point
the movie does elevate to being more
Hellraiser than another 2022 horror
movie with that premise it has its
growing pains what can I say but when
you get there when it becomes Hellraiser
you get there you get there with the
Vengeance you feel rewarded for getting
there I will say look I felt the cast
did a good job in this movie I wanted to
root for their characters more than I
ended up rooting for them at a point
where I was like all right I'm doing the
math and you're pretty much cenobike
cannon fodder now I'm looking forward to
the center bites killing you that's why
you're here you're bait and I was fine
with them being baked they had a little
more Edge to them than most group of
friends in a supernatural horror movie
have that said they never move past
being cenobate for me probably because I
started laughing at a point they just
they would scream at each other all the
time even before the supernatural stuff
starts going down screaming at each
other then the [ __ ] starts hitting the
fans screaming at each other there's a
group of people you would sit down you
just want to be like
do you feel this friendship is healthy
for any of you so I will say in a world
of remakes reboots remakeels
reimaginings all the wreaths Hellraiser
is one of those movies that I felt did
the legacy of Hellraiser Justice
Hellraiser has always been such a unique
premise to me you know there are so many
movies where Supernatural bad things are
happening and now people are gonna die
because of the supernatural baddies but
Hellraiser is distinctly Hellraiser it's
one of these rare cases where I get why
the reimagining happened but I will say
in a world of cenobites being cenobites
and Hellraiser being hellraisered I feel
like the original Hellraiser Say the
original two they can co-exist in a
universe with this Hellraiser it's not
like this undoes that right in my space
of head cannon that's just how it is
it's like oh yeah the original
Hellraiser exists and this Hellraiser
exists and it all happened and if that's
impossible because Hellraiser cannons
stop I'm taking this for me what can I
say ended up having myself a good time
no alcohol required based on this review
was I rooting for the Baddies
yeah
I'm cool with that and as I said before
this video is brought to you by raycon
earbuds raycon earbuds are those slick
stylish true wireless earbuds that come
in at about half the price of the
competition and still crank out that
sound because music without good sound
what's the point they have optimized gel
tips for a snug fit here comes the
demonstrations Tradition at this point
they're not gonna fall out of your head
you can cycle through the different
sound options by holding in the left
button on the left earbud for three
seconds really optimize how you like to
listen to your music raycon's been a
sponsor of my channel for a while
because I legitimately use these earbuds
every day use them while I'm working out
chilling listening to music listening to
music while passing the time doing
menial tasks and because convenience is
never overrated never out of date raycon
earbuds do offer wireless charging so
click the link below go to buy
raycon.com get yourself 15 off your
order and thank you very much to raycon
for sponsoring this video I do
appreciate that alright so Hellraiser
the new one the reimagining the 2022
Hulu Edition have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
foreign